[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand j'étais petit
j'ai eu la chance que mes parents
amènent souvent faire des randonnées à
la montagne ou des balades en forêt et
quand on passe une journée dehors il
arrive invariablement un moment où on a
envie de faire pipi
alors je sais pas vous mais quand
j'étais petit je me posais vraiment la
question c'est bien ou c'est pas bien de
faire pipi contre un arbre dans la forêt
comme ça je savais pas du tout
et surtout j'imagine pas du tout que
plus tard j'avais carrément faire une
thèse sur le fait de savoir si c'était
bien ou pas
et sur le fait de savoir comment on
pouvait faire nos besoins de façon
écologique
et ce qui est encore plus incroyable
c'est après cette thèse il y a eu tout
un tas de partenaires institutions qui
ont financé un programme de recherche
complet que j'ai l'honneur et la chance
de coordonner aujourd'hui le programme
Okapi à l'École des Ponts et je suis
chercheur au laboratoire les U pour avec
tous nos collègues réfléchir travailler
et construire ces manières de savoir
comment on peut faire nos besoins dans
un respect de la justice sociale et des
limites planétaires
alors imaginez vous êtes scientifique et
vous devez commencer à faire une
recherche sur le pipi qu'est-ce que vous
commencez par faire
non il s'agit pas de le faire maintenant
tout de suite ce soir en rentrant chez
vous vous faites tout ce que vous voulez
faites plein d'expérience là on va en
parler juste théoriquement mais
effectivement merci de leur a proposé il
s'agit déjà on va commencer par regarder
ce que c'est quoi donc première
expérience assez incroyable au lieu de
faire pipi dans une toilette à chasse
d'eau bah on fait pipi dans un récipient
finalement ça arrive pas si souvent que
ça et on peut regarder son urine tiens
c'est liquide
c'est chaud aussi tiens bah c'est vrai
ça a 37 degrés on y pense pas souvent
c'est jaune alors c'est jaune c'est
qu'il n'a pas pu avoir de l'eau d'avoir
des trucs dedans quand on est une
formation de chimiste on se dit bah
tiens on a qu'à enlever l'eau on va
assécher puis on va voir ce que c'est
alors on enlève l'eau c'est pas c'est un
si simple mais on peut y arriver et puis
à la fin on finit par analyser les
molécules qu'il y a dedans et on trouve
principalement de l'azote
donc le corps évacue plein d'autres dans
lequel il y a un peu d'azote qui dilué
d'où est-ce qu'il peut venir
s'il y a quelque chose qui sort de notre
corps
c'est probablement qu'à un moment il y a
du quelque chose qui est rentré dans
notre corps ainsi vous voulez faire une
autre expérience vous faites une
expérience de peser ce soir en rentrant
chez vous 25 mai 2023 vous vous pesez
dans un an 25 mai 2024 vous pesez aussi
on prendra les résultats de tout le
monde on fera une grosse moyenne je mets
la main à couper que on sera à peu près
tous au même poids donc globalement ça
veut dire que dans votre corps il y a de
l'azote qui est rentré mais en fait il y
a la même quantité d'azote qui est sorti
et effectivement on a besoin de manger
de l'azote sous forme de protéines on a
besoin de manger environ 60 grammes de
protéines par personne et par jour et
ces protéines le corps ne les recyclent
pas à l'infini une fois qu'il les a
utilisé il est obligé de les évacuer et
les évacuent sous une autre forme qui
est l'urée un des composants principal
de l'urine une molécule très riche en
azote et donc le corps humain a besoin
de manger des protéines l'azote sous
cette forme et d'évacuer de l'urée
alors maintenant si on remonte un peu la
chaîne on mange soit des animaux mais
les animaux eux-mêmes ont dû manger des
plantes de l'herbe par exemple pour la
vache soit on mange directement des
plantes du pain du blé des petits pois
etc et ces plantes elles-mêmes elles
sont constituées de protéines comment
est-ce que les plantes ont construit les
protéines dans leur corps et ben à
l'inverse des humains les plantes elles
prennent de l'azote dans le sol
typiquement sous la forme de l'urée et
avec de l'urée elles font des protéines
finalement on a un système qui tourne
extrêmement bien puisqu'on a des plantes
qui mangent de l'urée pour faire des
protéines et des humains et les animaux
en général qui ont besoin de manger les
protéines et qui extraitent ensuite
saturé et qui peut tourner ainsi à
l'infini et depuis des millions et des
millions d'années sur la planète Terre
c'est ainsi que fonctionnent les
écosystèmes et que circule l'azote entre
les plantes et les animaux les humains
évidemment ce sont inscrits dans ces
cycles les humains chasseurs-cueilleurs
fonctionnant ainsi jusqu'à un moment où
c'est beaucoup transformé la relation
des humains à l'environnement
l'invention de l'agriculture est-ce que
vous savez pourquoi à un moment et
comment les humains se sont mis à
devenir agriculteur
je vous rassure personne ne sait mais il
y a un grand nombre de chercheurs qui
émettent des hypothèses et en
particulier une hypothèse très
intéressante c'est qu'il y aurait eu des
cueilleurs chasseurs qui se seraient
sédentarisés et restant au même endroit
il y a eu énormément d'urines en
particulier de matières fertilisantes
qui se sont concentrées à cet endroit
que du coup la production de cet air ont
été très importante enrichie par cette
matière et que finalement ils sont
rentrés dans une relation avec des
plantes domestiquées cultivées et une
boucle entre les humains et les plantes
les plantes nourrissant les humains et
les humains nourrissant les plantes avec
leur engrais
alors si on regarde les traités
d'agriculture écrit par l'humanité par
principalement les grandes civilisations
qui nous ont laissé les traités de
l'agriculture on trouve invariablement
pléthore d'informations sur comment
utiliser l’urine humaine pour en faire
un engrais dans les Traités de Rome de
l'époque de Grèce les traités chinois
les traités indiens les traités arabes
on trouve à chaque fois 1000 détails
comment faire utiliser avec l'urine
humaine la vigne comment fertiliser le
blé comment fertiliser le pommier
comment fertiliser telle et telle
culture avec tous les détails du temps
de stockage la façon d'utiliser les
mélanges et toutes les pratiques depuis
des millénaires les humains l'ont
organisé et en particulier quand les
villes ont commencé à se développer
beaucoup de civilisations organisé un
aller-retour entre une campagne qui va
nourrir la ville et lui apporter ses
aliments les protéines
et puis les excréments humains qui vont
retourner vers les sols agricoles dans
un mutualisme entre les territoires
agricoles et les villes
ce système il sait également beaucoup
développé en France et au 19e siècle il
y avait une industrie florissante de
gestion des urines et matières fécales
humaines un cas particulier c'est celui
de la région des Flandres à Lille où
cette pratique était extrêmement
répandue et imaginez-vous locataire d'un
appartement à Lille au début du 19e
siècle bon ben on est locataire on paye
son loyer on a des charges mais il y a
une charge qui est complètement inversée
c'est celle de l'urine parce que l'urine
elle est stockée au pied de l'immeuble
et quand le vidangeur vient récupérer
l'urine il paye le locataire pour lui
acheter l'engrais qui fournit
au lieu de payer des charges on est payé
pour avoir ça
alors du coup comme dans n'importe quel
économie qui se met en place il commence
à y voir tout un tas de gens qui se
disent bah tiens il y a moyen
d'organiser cette économie et d'en tirer
des bénéfices alors il y a des il y a
des hangars qui se créent des modes de
transformation on transporte par bateau
on fait des expéditions dans tous les
sens de ces différentes matières et puis
il y a des gens aussi qui se disent
l'urine c'est pas très difficile de
rajouter un petit peu d'eau dedans vu
que les gens l'achètent au volume je
rajoute un peu d'eau et puis ça va
facilement être vendu beaucoup plus cher
donc il y avait des fraudes sur lui il
urine énorme alors imaginez-vous vous
êtes au début du 19e siècle ça fait 200
ans la disponibilité de de moyens
d'analyse de l'urine et pas celle qu'on
a aujourd'hui et vous devez vérifier que
la qualité de l'engrais quand vous
fournit est la bonne
qu'est-ce que vous faites
bah ouais
et il y avait un vrai métier ça
s'appelait courtier gourmet c'est très
bien décrit
c'est très bien décrit dans les ouvrages
du design siècle c'est une vraie
profession et donc ben oui on goûtait
pour vérifier qu'on avait pas frelaté
l'urine en la diluant avec de l'eau pour
la vendre plus cher
économie donc assez incroyable en tout
cas tel que nous vivons aujourd'hui on a
du mal à s'imaginer qu'elle a existé à
une si grande échelle au 19e siècle en
France et si on a du mal à s'imaginer
c'est parce que les transformations
étaient profondes dans le monde depuis
en particulier
au début du 20e siècle a été développé
une technique industrielle de synthèse
artificielle de l'azote pour ça il faut
énormément d'énergie on a allé la
chercher dans les hydrocarbures fossiles
et pour avoir de l'azote on a pris celui
qui est dans l'air le diazote l'azote de
l'air qui n'est pas disponible pour le
vivant ni pour les plantes ni pour les
animaux deux molécules d'azote très
fortement soudées mais avec énormément
d'énergie on peut briser cette liaison
des molécules d'azote et en faire de
l'azote typiquement de l'urée disponible
pour faire des engrais pour les plantes
c'est le procédé haber Bosch développé à
partir 1913 et à ce moment-là la
disponibilité en engrais azoté et donc
la capacité à produire des engrais a été
décuplé
finalement ce n'est plus été un facteur
limitant de la production de la
nourriture et progressivement on s'est
détourné des engrais organiques des
engrais naturels
dans les villes on avait construit des
égouts pour évacuer les eaux pluviales
finalement maintenant que les
agriculteurs n'étaient plus si
intéressés pour récupérer les
urines ou les matières fécales humaines
on a trouvé qui était assez pratique
avec une toilette à chasse d'eau de
brancher les maisons avec cet égout
pluvial et d'envoyer au loin les urines
des matières fécales dont toute façon
plus personne ne voulait
sauf que les égouts finissent dans la
rivière
et comme notre urine et de la nourriture
pour plante on fait pousser des algues
et des algues en quantité phénoménale
car les rivières sont toujours
relativement petites par rapport au
nombre d'habitants qui sont qui peuvent
habiter de sur la ville baignée par
cette rivière
alors on a créé des marées vertes et
dans les années 60 70 80 en France la
qualité de l'eau des rivières est
catastrophique et nous avons encore
maintenant aujourd'hui démarrer vertes
mais à cette époque beaucoup plus de
marée vertes dû entre autres à l'engrais
humain perdu des villes
alors pour résoudre ce problème
on a au bout des tuyaux des égouts
construit des stations de traitement des
eaux usées l'idée étant que les villes
évacues de l’eau usée un mélange d'eau
pluviale des eaux de la maison de la
douche de la cuisine des urines et
matières fécales qu'on mélange dans un
tuyau et puis à l'extrémité on ne veut
pas rejeter les matières contenues dans
cette eau dans la rivière alors on les
traite en station d'épuration
et quel est le procédé que fait la
station d'épuration pour traiter l'azote
l'azote est très diluée et on n'a pas
trouvé d'autres manières que de faire la
réaction exactement inverse des stations
de synthèse d'engrais azoté on détruit
les molécules du Ré ou assimilées
qui sont de l'engrais et on laisse
expédie dans l'atmosphère sous forme de
diazote il est perdu comme ressources
et on dépense aujourd'hui la même
quantité d'énergie et on émet à peu près
autant de gaz à effet de serre à un bout
de la chaîne par rapport à l'autre bout
pour synthétiser d'un côté et détruire
de l'autre cet engrais
usine de synthèse abord Bosch
engrais azoté qu'on met sur les champs
pris par la plante que l'on mange
on urine on appuie sur le bouton ça
disparaît
ça va à la station d'épuration et on
réémet dans l'atmosphère c'est azote
désormais perdu
comment penser
les manières de faire autrement quand
j'étais à l'école des Ponts il y a 20
ans
j'ai eu deux types de cours j'avais un
cours qui m'expliquait
on n'a pas d'hydrocarbure fossile ça
c'est hydrocarbures fossile qu'on brûle
participe à un changement climatique
extrêmement fort dangereux il faut se
détourner de l'utilisation de ses
ressources et essayer de baisser les
quantités d'énergie consommée à côté de
ça j'avais un autre cours un cours sur
le traitement des eaux usées qui nous
disait on est en situation
catastrophique la qualité des eaux de
rivière est très mauvaise il faut
absolument construire ces grandes usines
mais qui m'ont paru être des usines de
destruction d'engrais naturels
et j'ai vécu un certain traumatisme
d'imaginer qui paraissait si naturel
d'utiliser des ressources fossiles pour
détruire des ressources naturelles
est-ce que ça vous paraît logique
et ben figurez-vous il y a 20 ans
c'était absolument révolutionnaire
d'imaginer dire qu'on pouvait peut-être
faire autre chose que ce système
on a finalement abouti à un système
aberrant que l'histoire explique
et au final
les différents éléments qui se sont
succédés et les différents intérêts qui
ont joué ont abouti à cette histoire
mais on est face à un tableau
aujourd'hui
qui paraît aberrant
et dans la recherche que nous menons
depuis nombreuses années j'ai
l'impression d'avoir tiré sur un fil
progressivement en commençant par une
vision d'ingénieur bon c'est dommage de
synthétiser de l'azote et puis de
détruire de l'autre côté on peut pas
trouver autre chose et puis après en
fait il y a de plus en plus de choses
qui viennent en tirant sur le fil
d'abord on découvre que finalement il y
a jamais eu besoin d'avoir des engrais
de synthèse pétrochimiques pour nourrir
le monde
et puis on découvre aussi qu'il y a
jamais eu besoin d'avoir des
hydrocarbures fossiles pour avoir une
humanité qui soit épanouie puis elle au
bout de la chaîne on découvre qui a
jamais eu besoin
d'utiliser des litres et des litres
d'eau potable pour évacuer nos urines et
matières fécales
que ce n'est pas une fatalité que sur
terre aujourd'hui et 4 milliards de
personnes qui n'ont pas accès à des
conditions minimales d'assainissement
pendant que des dans les sociétés
occidentales on chie allègrement dans
l'eau potable
et peut-être ça vous paraîtra
anecdotique mais ce n'est pas non plus
une fatalité
qu'aujourd'hui quand on va au spectacle
les hommes utilisent le riz noir très
rapidement et les femmes fassent la
queue pendant si longtemps
finalement en étudiant ces différents
points on se rend compte qu'elle révèle
un certain nombre de choses
pour les toilettes elle révèle l'espace
public penser pareil pour les hommes
d'avantage pour les différentes façons
dont sont déployés les techniques dans
la société elle révèle aussi des
mécanismes de domination
des dominations qui produisent des
injustices sociales et des dommages
environnementaux qui nécessitent donc
d'être compris critiqué pour arriver à
tisser autrement des manières de faire
société
finalement il me semble qu'il y a deux
grands messages à passer autour de cette
façon de retisser le monde
la première ce serait celle de la
déconnexion au monde
qui d'entre vous sait d'où vient l'eau
quand vous ouvrez le robinet
qui d'entre vous sait comment a été
produit la nourriture que vous mangez
qu'est-ce qui a été mis sur les champs
comment ont été cultivés ces plantes
qui d'entre vous sait où vont les urines
et matières fécales une fois qu'on
appuie sur le bouton
notre société a produit une déconnexion
globale et elle a produit également plus
spécifiquement pour les ingénieurs une
certaine neutralisation politique
car aucune technique n'est neutre toutes
les techniques sont enchassées dans un
système politique et dans une
organisation collective dans lesquelles
les ingénieurs souvent
ont une position plutôt confortable
ils ne sont pas spontanément de nature à
remettre en cause un système qui les
sert plutôt bien alors même que cette
technique est à repenser dans sa
capacité à faire société
j'ai encadré un premier doctorant qui a
travaillé sur l'urine on a fait des
essais de fertilisation pour voir
comment est-ce qu'on pouvait utiliser
désormais à nouveau ses engrais en
essayant déployer une recherche qui soit
autant que possible conviviale intégré
et dans une logique d'axe d'incapacité
de donner de la puissance d'agir à des
collectifs et aux citoyens pour
réinventer ces nouvelles manières de
faire
et puis juste après un autre doctorat
qui même voire et qui me dit d'encadrer
une thèse sur le pipi et le caca
finalement
c'est vrai c'est pas juste on s'était
pas beaucoup occupé du caca alors là
quand il est venu me voir je lui ai dit
t'inquiète pas on va faire la teste sur
le caca parce que je suis pas sûr qu'il
y aura beaucoup d'étudiants qui vont
revenir me voir pour me demander ça le
pipi il y a de l'azote on peut le vendre
et tout mais le caca vraiment c'est pas
glamour et là aussi on découvre qu'en
fait finalement le caca aujourd'hui un
de ces grands problèmes c'est les
risques de transmission de maladie de
pathogènes mais aujourd'hui c'est
pathogène on les retrouve dans les
rivières le système qu'on a développé ne
permet pas de garantir une barrière sur
le transfert de ces pathogènes entre
nous et l'environnement
et donc on a des remises en cause
écologiques sociales mais également
sanitaires de ces manières de faire
société
et aujourd'hui un très grand nombre
d'acteurs
sont en train d'apprendre à savoir
comment est-ce qu'on peut développer des
urinoirs sans eau pour les hommes des
urines noires sans eau pour les femmes
des toilettes à séparation d'urine des
façons de collecter de stocker de
transformer les urines les matières
fécales pour en faire des métiers
fatiguant
et ici même à l'École des Ponts nous
avons développé une collecte de l'urine
et un démonstrateur avec valorisation de
saturing sur les champs et des
partenariats avec des agriculteurs un
boulanger qui nous permettent
aujourd'hui de faire du pain à partir de
cette ressource produite quotidiennement
par nos corps
alors revenons à la question initiale
est-ce que c'est bien ou pas bien de
faire pipi dehors et ben en fait
d'abord il faut pas faire pipi dans
l'eau
dans l'eau on va diluer ses ressources
et puis globalement on va contribuer à
la croissance des algues dans les
écosystèmes ce qui va créer des marées
vertes
ensuite on peut se dire on peut faire
pipi sur la pierre très mauvaise idée
aussi vous l'avez déjà expérimenté
l'azote va partir sous forme
d'ammoniaque dans l'atmosphère l'odeur
est horrible il reste la paire assez
bonne idée mais finalement pas
nécessairement n'importe quelle terre on
peut à sa propre échelle fertiliser de
la terre pour produire mais un des
enjeux qui est devant nous aujourd'hui
c'est de savoir comment organiser à
grande échelle le fait que l'engrais
humain produit par nos corps soit
intégrés dans des systèmes qui
permettent d'être retournés au sol pour
boucler le cycle du vivant
merci
[Applaudissements]